bene a tutti ragazzi benvenuti questo
video io sono file j
e oggi siamo e pino nuovo episodio di
unboxing sigla mi piace perché l'unica
serie in cui può effettivamente una
sigla quindi ricorsi di la può partire
si era buttata lì oggi ragazzi facciamo
non so perché
facciamo che compare il pacco facciamo
che compa pacco e questo abbiamo desco
farlo però oggi si spera gli autori di
ricordo normale non ho nessuno che mi dà
una mano nel farlo quindi oggi pesca
togliamo by myself poi ringrazio gli
autori per tentare l'omicidio in ogni
video proviamo a te scatolare il parco
di oggi ragazzi voi sapete bene sempre
dal titolo di cosa si tratta io
fortunatamente no sappiamo abbiamo non
c'è niente invece pac man
abbiamo l'aria che non è male
inconsapevolmente mi hai fatto il pacco
con la cosa più bella che potesse mai
ricevere dentro il parco a parte gli
scherzi c'è una sola cosa no due ci sono
più cose sepolte da questo partiamo con
la prima che io per questo fatto e non
ho ancora capito cosa c'è dentro però va
beh allora abbiamo ciò che non capitano
è un po abbiamo una strategies filef il
board se voi sapete cos'è
contenti voi lorenzo c'è secondo me mio
marito aiutante il cane pane mentre
mercato se non in quanto tutto merito ma
io ho un aiutante per oggi quindi tra
tutte le persone che mi sono capitate in
unboxing fosse lui è il più
collaborativo ho trovato un cane che
forse ti rimpiazza secondo è un gioco
per cani allora fortunatamente una cosa
veloce da leggere quindi lo posso fare
prima che il mio cane scappi l'ebit e le
cavità con le leccornie il presente
il vostro cane e lasciatele mezzi aperte
questo permetterà il cane di trovare i
pro di trovare più velocemente delle
cornici ed avere un successo più abito
qui devo riempirlo di leccornie che
saranno dentro una scatola andiamo ad
aprire le leccornie
apriamo una leccornia per cani questo mi
sembra più leccornia per me questa è la
e corniglia per uomo per cane prima di
inserirli all'interno e vedere cosa
succede se sanno riesce in qualche modo
a tirarli fuori
adesso ma adesso ti faccio vedere allora
abbiamo all'interno dei dolci per canino
vedi dove ti piace loro ciclica non
piace e impacchettato e noi spacchettata
darlo vedi questo va dal prima 12 di
oggi che vorrei puntualizzare guardavano
e berlusconi signori baum phone
dopo questa battuta potrei uccidermi
propri ma vediamo 7 gustano io ho
preparato qua questo giochino lo vedi ci
stanno proprio di pop corn dentro guarda
a per i tuoi questo bob corn questo qua
sta già facendo ha gustato se tu gusti
il bob corn zen di bono prendi la
zampina e devi aprire e dopo di che stai
concorde project di addebito della
fortezza del mio cane lupo attenzione e
primo c'è la persona che vi apre così è
dai dai ora che sono i limiti edifici di
quelli residenti vo in questo senso si
guarda uno stop a ci manca ma qua
ecco se l'altro lo vuoi stata sotto
mistico a capire perfetto bravo il
prossimo passo è quello di diventare il
presidente degli stati uniti
se vuoi altri rosolio web ascoltami
chiudiamo col prossimo esercizio nonché
mini gioco per cani che troviamo nella
scatola ricordare una cosa aspetta a
bari ma qua è seduto prossimo giochino
per un cane molto tra allora se proviamo
a stare fermi in un secondo vediamo
ancora esiste allora questo devi devi
fare chimica la chimica non ci riuscivo
a farne anche io a voi la forchetta devi
girare i cosi ok tu puoi fare la stessa
cosa ha capito allora se tu giri questo
scade trucchetto capito e quindi gira
qua
basa su una lettura o suggerimenti
diciamo che sun con questa roba qua sono
e lo stesso rapporto che avevo io con la
chimica niente crocchette per il cane
che forse è meglio visto che ha mangiato
da 200 con corna quindi ragazzi giochi
sono andati bene ma non benissimo
vediamo cosa ne pensa dei dolci in
generale su prometterli sul tavolo allo
ragazze di un sacco di cose che credo
che hasan piacciono soprattutto le
ciambelle tipo cornei fa gli stenti
seduto un biscotto seduto e bravissimo
stare seduto lì che mi sorprende un
sacco visto che non lo fa mai passiamo
al prossimo cibo oggi degusta lui non
faccio niente indotto cv e allora qua
abbiamo degli oggetti seduto seduto some
seduto seduto ok non lo farò
lo farò
raga noi stiamo l'anno nel dolci ok
[Musica]
il mio cane quei rumori diventa un mezzo
va bè ragazzi abbiamo visto una
bestiolina mangiare per un'ora e mezza
onde evitare che al mio canale disco più
fegato magari non facciamo di mangiare
tutto perché non è che vanno e non date
troppo da mangiare ai cani che poverini
sono gli fa male quindi lavoro vogliono
mangiare un sacco contenetevi contenete
la vostra tenerezza quindi ti vorrei
dare tutto no però ti darò una cosa sola
ogni compleanno tu stai a port per
sempre passiamo al prossimo the scatola
mento per vedere che cosa succede tu
perché non stai fermo come i cani
imbalsamati andiamo su io credo che il
mio cane sia veramente iniziato questo
neanche il cane la ferragni champagne e
per cani
io non ho capito però va bè ragazzi sa
di champagne
lo stiamo dando al chiare già sicuri che
sia commestibile
proviamo a vedere lo champagne e per
cani con la tua tutto ubriaco mi
raccomando non guidare perché poi in
casi cin cin alla tua sidro di mele che
il comico a volta che a noi e allora
ragazzi e funzionano champagne e
applicare dal quindi blu blu a parte
vediamo se riusciamo a trovare qualcosa
altri questa scatola fantastica abbiamo
mentre si continua a trangugiare si ci
lascia pali che è finito da un ora
abbiamo un sacco di giochi per cani
finalmente una roba che non si distrugge
lo sono visto che stiamo in 16 ore
questa è una coscia di pollo
non so se tu tieni te lo regalo è tuo
lei quindi ragazzi questo era il bivio
più strano che io abbia mai fatto
sicuramente con il miccoli mio cane
credo che sia opportuno dire che il mio
cane è veramente intelligente a volte
forse anche più del padrone io ringrazio
some per aver partecipato a questo video
del quale sicuramente non è contento
sicuramente lupi soddisfatto della
partecipazione
io ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto come al solito seguito è
piaciuto lasciato un bel commento è un
mi piace anche per sun e sapersi
schiette e non ci vediamo subito
[Musica]